hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime operor and the secret of
asta's true power and true identity is
being unraveled right in front of us in
my previous black clover video i argued
that asta's birth as the flaw of the
world was no coincidence and that wizard
king julius was likely the man who
fathered him and i don't just mean that
in the physical sense julius may have
used complex magic powers and rituals to
divide the time magic devil asteroth's
soul into separate pieces and with these
pieces he created both asta and liebe as
the ultimate secret weapon for fighting
lucius does that sound a little too
crazy well i'm gonna explain everything
right now you guys know how this works
leave a quick like and comment to help
us out with that youtube algorithm it
only takes you a second but it means a
lot and of course if you want a
completely free way of supporting the
channel right now click that subscribe
button click that bell and select the
option that says all finally this video
will of course contain black over manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so i think
that the recent events surrounding
lucius being able to purify devil magic
will turn out to be the key to
everything this purification ability has
completely changed the game in black
clover it reshaped the entire power
system and the consequences of this
change will be massive
after purifying his own devil magic and
then turning sister lily into some sort
of angel devil hybrid lucius was able to
land a serious physical attack on asta
who was clearly distracted by everything
that was happening to sister lily lucius
then declares that asta doesn't even
have the strength to move after that
attack and he claims that asta only has
a few minutes left to live asta being
asta refuses to give up and his allies
noel mimosa and sacre quickly rush to
help him since they can tell that asta's
life is in danger but we then see sister
lily using beelzebub's spatial magic to
stop noel's attack in its tracks
lucius explains that he incarnated and
purified beelzebub's magic inside of
lily using his soul magic and so she now
possesses the ability to use spatial
magic just like xenon used to possess
lucius was somehow able to incarnate
beelzebub's magic into sister lily and
then purify it in a matter of seconds
and then sister lily instantly became a
faithful servant of lucius this is a
level of magical prowess that we haven't
seen yet in black clover and it really
seems like lucius's power is approaching
the level of a god in fact lucius
explains that he took control of all the
remaining supreme devils in the
underworld including all the overpowered
ones on the lowest levels but it's
important to remember that one supreme
devil is no longer inside the underworld
because he went missing and that devil's
name is of course asteroth now unlike
the other devil hosts who either served
devils or had contracts with them lucius
plans to use purified devil magic to
allow humanity to ascend to new heights
he will use purified devil magic to give
humans nearly indestructible bodies and
the boundless wisdom and sister lily is
only the first of these so-called
paladins that lucius plans to create he
will use these paladins to rule over the
entire world as the ultimate wizard king
and this new world that lucius creates
will be better for everyone because it
will be a world of peace order and
happiness noel mimosa and sacrament make
another attempt to reach asta and mimosa
especially is determined to heal his
injuries but they are again stopped by
an even bigger and even more powerful
spatial magic spell created by sister
lily sister lily then repeats to asta
that his death will bring about world
peace and it seems clear that she has
been completely brainwashed by lucius
the angelic transformation that he just
put her through didn't just affect her
physical appearance and magical power it
also seems to have warped her very mind
and it makes her completely obedient to
lucius and while that sucks for the
person who is being turned into one of
these paladins for lucius it's pretty
great because it ensures complete
loyalty sensing that sister lily is
being manipulated osta swears that he
will save her but before he can even
finish that sentence sister lily
launches an offensive attack right at
him and he is seemingly blown away by
the impact and while we don't see asta's
body since it seems to have disappeared
into the building on top of which he has
been lying noel mimosa and sacre are
both deeply shocked and worried by what
they just saw lucius declares that it is
done the flaw of the world has been
eliminated mazda is apparently dead at
least according to lucius and the
judgment day will arrive in seven days
that is when the final crusade will
begin and that is when lucius intends to
create his perfect and peaceful world
lucius is confident in his ultimate
victory because he has seen the future
and he knows that he is still about to
be attacked by the magic squad captains
because that is something that he has
also foreseen as all those captains who
were present at asta ceremony rush at
lucius including of course our boy yami
lucius doesn't look worried at all once
they get close to lucius the captains
are shocked to see an enemy who looks
almost exactly like the wizard king but
yami quickly confirms that this person's
magic and ki are completely different
still yami must sense that julius is
still in there somewhere because he
screams out julius's name and he even
uses an honorific to refer to julius
which is something that yami almost
never does he just isn't the type of guy
to use honorifics when addressing people
so this emphasizes just how important
julius is to yami and how much yami
respects him the action ends as sister
lily seemingly initiates another spatial
magic spell although it's not yet clear
what exactly happened the implication is
that sister lily may have just
teleported both herself and lucius out
of harm's way
using spatial magic and this then leads
us to wonder was asta really killed or
was he teleported somewhere else i mean
what am i saying of course he wasn't
killed this is black clover the real
question is whether asta's injured body
is still somewhere inside that building
because he got smashed through the
building by lily's spell or whether he
was teleported somewhere else because
lucius has other plans for asta plans
that may involve experimenting on osta
and liba and maybe even somehow
purifying anti-magic in order to create
the ultimate magic power in fact perhaps
lucius needs asta and liba in order to
unlock the true power of the ultimate
supreme devil the time magic devil
asteroth
and speaking of asteroth let's talk
about why i believe that asta may
actually be the time devil asteroth
himself or rather osta and liebe
together may represent the two halves of
asteroth allow me to explain in my
previous black clover video which i will
link down in the description i argued
that asta's birth as a flaw of nature a
flaw of the world was not just some
random coincidence the fact that asta
was like the only known human born
without magic who just happened to be in
the right place at the right time to
receive the very grimoire where lee bit
the anti-magic devil was sealed cannot
just be some insane cosmic coincidence i
mean if it was a coincidence it would
just be so unbelievable what are the
chances that the one guy born without
magic comes across the one grimoire that
holds the one devil who doesn't have
magic but he does have anti-magic which
is a power that only osta can wield
because he is the only human who doesn't
have magic oh and as a cherry on top
both of these guys happen to share the
same mother you know just for good
measure i argued that because julius has
been aware of lucius's plans for decades
all this time he has been secretly
searching for a way to defeat lucius his
solution was to ensure that asta would
be born without magic and he likely made
sure that austin liebe would come into
contact with each other when they did
julius has spent many years searching
for rare magical powers and abilities
and when he came across lychita and her
absorption magic he finally found what
he needed in order to create the
ultimate weapon against lucius
this means that julius is likely austa's
father although it's not yet clear
whether he is asked as biological father
or whether he just engaged in some
magical shenanigans with lychita's baby
after she was already pregnant i noticed
that in the comments of my previous
video a lot of people seem to forget
that leachita's magic doesn't just drain
a person's mana it also drains a
person's life force which means that
theoretically even someone without magic
would still have a life force and so
they would still be affected by
lychita's absorption devils are an
exception though lichita can drain their
mana but not their life force which is
why liebe a magicless devil was able to
be around lichita without any issues
however asta couldn't stay around her
because even without magic he still had
life force and so theoretically if
leechita's ability continued to absorb
this life force he would have died and
so lichita was ultimately forced to give
asta up for adoption but here's the
thing lychita was pregnant with asta for
nine months he was a living being with
his own unique life force growing inside
of her in theory lychee's absorption
ability should have killed him while he
was still just a baby in her womb unless
she was approached by someone such as
say wizard king julius and that someone
offered her a way to protect asta at
least while he was still inside her womb
in exchange lychita may have allowed
julius to make certain modifications to
asta and that is what allowed him to
survive and be born healthy after 9
months
what if asta wasn't initially supposed
to be born without magic what if he had
both mana and life force but julius used
complex magic spells and rituals to
modify him and this modification is what
allowed him to survive
but this modification is also what
turned osta into the flaw of the world
the only human born without magic and
thus the only human capable of using
anti-magic and what if julius was also
behind the birth of liebe a devil who
just happened to be born without magic
in the underworld at about the same time
that asta was born without magic in the
human world and this could all tie into
the real reason why asteroth suddenly
disappeared from the underworld and why
we still haven't seen him anywhere
one thing that i didn't look at in my
previous video but which was very
popular in the comments of that video is
the idea that julius somehow extracted
asteroth's soul from his time magic then
split that soul into two parts and
placed one part in asta and the other
part in libre or he used one part to
create asta and the other part to create
libe because julius kept time magic for
himself and asteroth's soul was left
magicless both osta and liebe were also
born magicless and this hidden
connection could explain why they happen
to look very similar to each other and
why they happen to be roughly the same
age because asta and liba are two parts
of one hole and since they both came
from the same soul they were destined to
meet once again and form one whole one
perfect devil union although to be fair
julius may have secretly facilitated
their first encounter from the shadows
and this brings me back to that concept
of purifying devil magic that lucius
keeps talking about
what if purifying devil magic actually
means using soul magic to separate a
devil's magic power from that devil's
soul and this allows lucius and his
paladins to use the magic of a devil
such as beelzebub's spatial magic
without having to worry that the devil
will take over their body the devil
can't take over because the magic has
been purified it has been separated from
the devil's soul and that is exactly
what could have happened to asteroth and
his time magic his magic may have been
purified and taken in by julius
lucius
but then julius secretly split his soul
into two and used it to create asta and
liber two creatures who together form
the ultimate weapon for defeating lucius
it's funny but asta is of course one
half of the word asteroth but here's the
crazy part that you may have missed the
word liber means love in german and the
devil asteroth was actually based on an
ancient pagan deity called astarte who
in this ancient pagan religion was
considered to be the goddess of love so
while asta's name might have been a very
obvious clue that asta is the first half
of asteroth liebe's name may actually be
a more subtle clue that he is the second
half osta and liebe being astroth would
explain a lot of other mysteries as well
like why liba is so strong despite
allegedly being a lowest ranked devil
and why asta manifests that mysterious
fifth horn while in his devil union form
it could be because both osta and liebe
actually have supreme devil properties
and if all of this is true if asta and
liebe together form two halves of one
hole two halves of the supreme devil
asteroth then the more they are able to
perfect their devil union the closer
they will be to resurrecting astarov
himself and once they unite perfectly as
one asteroth will finally be revealed
and he may even reclaim his original
magic time magic just imagine what that
final form of asta and liebe would look
like the supreme devil asteroth using
the magic that had always belonged to
him the ultimate magic type
time magic and that is why the ending of
chapter 335
could be so important
if lucius and sister lily kidnapped asta
in order to perform some magical
experiments or rituals on him rituals
that may or may not involve purification
they may end up triggering a
transformation with an asta that
ultimately resurrects asteroth and when
astaroth is ultimately resurrected then
all bets are off we have no idea what
asteroth would be like will he be a good
guy like osten lieben will he be evil
will he be looking for revenge against
lucius and julius the possibilities are
endless and endlessly fascinating and i
can't wait to see what happens next if
you're looking for a video to watch next
check out my previous black clover video
where i went into further detail on why
i think that julius may have fathered
asta i will link that video down in the
description and in the end credits you
guys know the drill if you enjoy our
black clover content leave a quick like
and comment right now to help out with
that youtube algorithm and if you're new
here or you just haven't taken the time
to subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications if you don't go
through the steps of subscribing hitting
that bell and then selecting the option
that says all you are still gonna miss a
ton of our black clover videos even if
you are subscribed it's just how youtube
works i want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime outpour patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the toasted qi corey mcgowan big
buddhist and jeremy pontier and i can't
forget all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor fat boy games
kaido might be a duck alivania and anime
s codem if you guys enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon or
here through youtube memberships even a
single dollar helps and it means a lot
to us as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys